today's one minute monday is build a  team  i just got off the line with my media  coach uh jenny i'm going over some of my  videos and it just  it just sunk in again how important it  is to have a team you cannot do  all of this yourself okay when you are  starting up it is all you it's solo but  you have to  find a way to bring people on board who  believe the same thing as you do because  that's gonna  that's when your company will explode  and i'm so grateful for  for jenny and adis and jason and  christina and manzour  and all the people on my team all the  people who make this happen right these  videos will not happen without my team  my website would not happen without my  team  you have to start thinking how you can  get people involved because the company  that you have in your head  to achieve massive success to have an  impact to build your movement you cannot  do this alone you need to build a team  believe  you